very Michael all right thank you so I
want to talk about algebraic circular
bounds and if you have such low bounds
what do you get in terms of D
randomization this is sort of be a
vignette of recent work it's not gonna
be like the latest and greatest but it's
something which is a nugget which I hope
you can take away it's going to be sort
of taking these algebraic circuit level
rounds making them or bust in some way
and say that they're sort of immediately
gives some derealization so this is
based on various joint works with the
mesh program okay so what is the theme
of this talk is this question sort of
surrounding this workshop so is that if
you have some circuit class you have a
lower bound for that sir class what does
that give you in terms of algorithms for
deciding properties circuits from that
class what I want to focus on here is
actually one focus on deterministic
algorithms the sense that here the
properties i'm interested in there will
be automatically easy randomized
algorithms the question is can you d
randomized as everyone's so why am I
asking these the specific version of
this question well clearly I want to be
randomized some algorithms but more
broadly is that there is this idea that
you can take lower bounds and D
randomized things based on that in this
harness around in this paradigm but
oftentimes the circuit classes that will
be interested in are just gonna be too
weak to instantiate this connection so
we really have to answer this question
by looking at those lower bounds a fresh
right and there's some idea that really
you know understanding the lower bounds
in a way is really to get algorithms is
like a the best way you can understand
little round you don't really understand
them until you get an algorithm okay so
I want to talk about lower bounds and
algorithms from them but what am I
actually what are these properties I'm
trying to decide well the main property
is that of nonzero pneus so there's this
punim of any testing question what is
this question I'm giving you a
polynomial it's gonna be multivariate
can really be over any large enough
field that you want I'll just stick to
the rationals for this talk you're given
this polynomial you want to know is it 0
or not okay so it's a very simple
question but the main subtlety in here
is what does it mean to be given a
polynomial I mean there's many ways to
get Apollo get it in the mail you go to
be email I don't know but what I mean to
be given a polynomial it's i'm going to
give you to you as a small computational
device okay so for example you can
consider x squared minus y squared you
could factor it as X plus y times X
minus y and I want to say that I'm sort
of giving it to you in some
computational way and how is that spy
formulas follows right so this is a tree
you have sort of variables at the bottom
you have scalars from your field of
addition and multiplication and if you
have an object like this this naturally
computes some polynomial
so what I could do is I could you know
have formulas like this I could send it
to you via email you'll be getting a
polynomial you want to know did you get
some non-trivial email you want to know
did I send you as your opponent me or
not that's followed by digitizing
question okay so this is a question this
is the property I'm trying to decide of
a given circuit class what do we know
about that well there's this you know
well known lemma do the short and simple
that says that if you have a nonzero
polynomial it's non 0 if and only if you
have it's not nonzero valuation points
for random evaluation books ok so this
easily gives you a randomized algorithm
for deciding on 0 nez you get one of
these formulas you just plug in random
values to the variables and you evaluate
the formula you want to know is that
corresponding value should point 0 or
not so that's a very easy randomized
algorithm and furthermore it has the
property that it's black box in the
sense that you don't actually need to
look at the formula and understand the
structure of how it's actually wired you
just need to use the formula to evaluate
the underlying polynomial and see if
that evaluation 0 or not so we have a
randomized black box algorithm and we
want to know is there the corresponding
deterministic algorithm and when you in
particular you want maybe a
deterministic black box I'll really only
uses evaluation points and you can
imagine other elements but for this talk
let's black box and in this case you can
the equivalent notion here is something
called a hitting set which is a set
equivalent to black box PID thinks that
is a set of tuples it'll be a set of
input points sort of cool eh and as a
property that for any small formulas
tiny computationally in simple f that
polynomial will be 0 or correspondingly
non 0 if and only if it's nonzero on the
evaluation points so the runtime of your
algorithm is really corresponding to the
number of evaluation points in your
hitting sex you want a small set and
because we're restricting just simple
functions we know that there exists not
a very small hitting sets not
collectively and the question is can you
an algorithmically construct one of
these hitting sets I said this is the
property I want to decide you have a
some circuit class decide your whether
it's not 0 via this sort of hitting a
set approach this is but then the
question is what is the circuit class I
want to talk about there's many
different types when I want tell you
today is a very simple type is called
the depth repowering formulas which is
not super familiar to many of you but
i'll tell you about anyways okay so an
algebraic formula typically when you
compute multiple Omiya you use things
like addition and multiplication but
it's very familiar thing to change your
gate set so what are other gate sets
that are natural in a setting where you
consider addition and powering okay so
you can
XY that's a multiplication x times y and
you can actually express it as the
difference of two powers X plus y
squared and X minus y squared so it's
saying that in terms of gate sets
addition and powering is the same thing
as addition and multiplication so engine
for general formulas but the problem is
that if you actually try to do this
verse a load up formulas this edition
break this equivalence breaks down for
sort of you can do it so it's not going
to hold your load depth so question is
what happens when we say restrict
ourselves to low depth powering circuits
specifically we talk about depth
repowering formulas these turn out to be
something called the sums of powers of
linear form so if we write it out we
have a plan b f of x is we have x 1 up
to xn we're going to have a big
summation gate sort of s things here and
then we take a sum a linear form and we
take to some power we're sort of
thinking of this power is maybe like
pantel meal and end like n squared or 10
or anywhere in between and we have these
constants coming from our field so you
have a sum of powers of linear forms and
I think for most people you ask you know
ask yourself why are we studying this
and I asked myself that sometimes too
but there's some question that this is
actually a very fundamental model in a
sense it's sort of a moral analog of cns
and DNFs it's very very simple it's very
very weak and yet it's sort of we still
don't fully understand it as prick
shipment yesterday we don't have you
know optimal pseudo-random generators
for DNFs we don't have optimal hitting
sets for this model either and this is
sort of an obstacle to understanding
further progress on larger models okay
so it really was intersection of many
techniques we still don't have a good
understanding but we do have some
understanding what understanding we have
we have lower bounds with this model so
what is one lower bound is following
consider the monomial x 1 times x 2 up
to xn this actually requires exponential
size to be computed as a depth
repowering formula now in some sense
this is embarrassing because the
monomials in some sense a very very
simple polynomial and sometimes it's
sort of like parody if you think about
it in terms of the plus minus one basis
so there's some analog with a parody not
an AC 0 here but this monomial takes
exponential size as a lower bound
there's also a corresponding upper bound
these definitely prior formulas can
compute anything so this is this a lower
bound it's it's even for the monomial I
mean obviously it applies to things like
the permanent to determine and so on so
this is what we know it's basically
proven by this partial derivative nice
understanding sort of explicitly notice
by Kyle one thing I
here when I was Simon's last year's
actually this is actually known to
mathematicians in 1850s so you know it
does have a illustrious history the
lower bound what does it tell us about
say design deciding nonzero eNOS well
the result I sort of want to tell you
about a of the following suppose that
give you one of these formulas now take
it and express it as a polynomial like
just expand all of monomials or giving
many many monomials this polynomial will
actually be determined by its
restriction to those monomials on very
few variables those purses for a second
there are many many monomials here if
the monomial involves more than say log
as variables just throw it away so it's
like zero out that coefficient you'll be
left with the sum of monomials where
each manami lost few variables that
which variables might depend on the
monomial but you'll have very very few
minutes you'll have a quality panel many
monomials left and I'm saying those
coefficients actually determine the
function so this is some sort of
structure result sort of corresponding
to like lineal amendments or Nissan's
result in ac0 about for concentration
its sleep some algebraic analog ok so
it's saying that f is determined by you
sort of very few monomials and you
actually you can easily get a hitting
set of claws eponymous eyes based on
this so this is a structure without
giving hitting set and how do we
actually prove it I want to sort of tell
you about it a statistically by taking
this lower bound and making it robust in
some way which is actually fairly easy
in retrospect so I want to talk about
this now but to do it I need to tell you
about the lower bound how does that go
the size refer to the first cement of
the second
and size s so s is the number of
summations you have here so there's sort
of various parameters d will sort of be
Paul Mele bounded s could be anything
from one to exponential and the number
of variables always be n all right so
here's how does lower-brow go it's a
sort of familiar path there's something
called the complexity measure it some
measure that you can assign to any
polynomial the car you know is roughly
corresponds to how complicated it is so
what is the measure that we're
interested in here it's this partial
derivative method so you have a
polynomial its end variables what we're
going to do is because it's sort of both
with rationals you can think about
taking derivatives right you can kind of
remember calculus you can take
derivatives of polynomial so when you
take a derivative of panola you get
another polynomial okay what you're
gonna do is you're going to take all
possible derivatives all possible ways
so take the X n variable and take the
differential respect to a n times look
at the X 1 variable take a 1 times you
do all of these derivatives you're going
to get an exponentially large set of
polynomials you take that set and then
you take all linear combinations this is
now a vector space and you take a
dimension and that's that's this the
measure here it's not super important
what it is at the moment but this is the
complexity measure and what do we know
about in terms of facts well it's pretty
easy to see that its sub additive
because this is linear algebra linear
algebra is metrical but more importantly
we can actually say that if you have a
power of a linear form then the measure
is small ok so why is this this is
roughly because of the chain rule right
you have this linear form and you take
it to the deeth power what happens when
you take one derivative when you take
one derivative the D will sort of pop
down the exponent will go from D to D
minus 1 and then you multiply by a
derivative of the inner function the
point is that a derivative of a linear
polynomial is simply a constant right so
what happen is when you take a
derivative constants will sort of pop
out the exponent will decrease by one
but the point is is that we're taking
the dimension of a span and so you're
just sort of basically you're ignoring
constants anyways so from the
perspective of this collection measure
when you take a derivative all you're
doing is decreasing this exponent by one
so the space of derivatives is simply
the expo powers of this single Paulo
meal where you go from D to D minus 1
all the way down
zero you get P plus one of them that's
why this measure is small okay and then
you can sort of expect what would come
next is that the measure of the monomial
is very very large right so if you take
a monomial and take a derivative it
basically just kills that variable that
you took a derivative to so basically
when you take all derivatives you get
all subsets of size of a universe of
size n there to the end of them that's
why it's due to yet ok you can bind
these three things and you immediately
get the lower bound that the monomial
needs exponential size to be computed
this way right you you apply new to both
sides use civetta tivity and they each
of the sum and has small measure ok this
is assuming that the X you know the
exponents are small but you can sort of
remove that with another argument ok so
this is the lower bound you can see it's
like fairly simple and obviously you
know it can be generalized in a lot of
different ways the question is how do we
actually use this to get identity
testing how do we you know you given one
of these formulas you want to know is it
0 or not ok so we were going to make
this robust to do that let's try to
understand what a lower bound is telling
us what a lower bound is telling us is
if I give you a small formula you
immediately know it's not computing the
monomial because if it was computing the
middle meal it would violate the lower
bound so that's telling you something
about whether about the plan omegle does
not necessarily telling you whether it's
0 or not but can we push this in some
way well one way we could try to push it
is does it is there a way and sense in
the sense that if I give you one of
these things can it approximately
compute large monomials is if it could
not approximately compute my own oils
maybe that would tell us something more
let's do an example or if we do an
example we have power of this linear
form when you expand it out you
immediately get this really really large
Gnomeo and that seems to be problematic
because like maybe in some sense this
linear form is approximately computing
this large monomial which would refute
you know this question there something
that okay but it turns out that the
answer is really no in this because
there is other stuff going on here like
their other monomials like X 1 to the n
X n to the N and i want to say those are
ruining this any sense in which this
linear form is computing this
approximately this middle meal so how
can you make that precise will you do
the following suppose I give you a
nonzero polynomial say computed by one
of these formulas what you're going to
do is you're going to take F and express
it as the leading monomial plus lower
order terms and how do I make this
distinction between the highest term and
the lowest term you can take a monomial
and you can order it look so graphically
by doing the following you you take the
first variable x1
that's a really really big variable and
then x2 is slightly big you're slightly
but slightly smaller and then you xn is
the smallest variable and when you order
all of these monomials lexa graphically
you can you know this gives you a total
ordering of monomials you can very
clearly see what is the leading monomial
and if you go back to this example what
is the leading monomial it's not this
big metal meal it's X 1 to the N because
x1 is so big be based on this ordering
okay and so now we can say what is the
robust lower bound we can say the fact
is that the complexity measure are just
defined for you has the property that
for any F the measure of f is at least
the measure of the leading monomial okay
so its robust to these lower order terms
right you can sort of throw away these
loader terms which we kind of think it
was like error terms or something okay
and once you have this robust framework
you get the immediate structure result
by applying lower bound that says that
for any small formula computed in this
model the leading monomial must involve
very few variables okay and then if you
push it a little bit you can get the
shark shoulders of dementia in the last
slide but the main point is that you you
take this leading manami about on the
number of variables and you immediately
get this hitting set okay okay so this
is how you make the robot things you
take a lower bound you make a robust and
you get a hitting said more generally
you know what's really going on I can
now conclude with some conclusions a
robust lower bound is basically
something where you take a polynomial
and you identify some extreme aspect
something like a leading monomial you
have a complexity measure where it
happens to be that new of it of the
extrema plus lower order terms is at
least knew of the extrema and you can
conclude from that that the extreme it
must be very very simple now this seems
a kind of restrictive in the sense that
leading monomials that like we really
use the fact that the lower bound of
sore monomial and that seems to be
important but there are other instances
of this some various other works that
have used this idea or the following but
this is still sort of an emerging theme
in this area of research about taking
lower bounds making the robust and
getting algorithms out of bed and there
are still some open questions open
question it was I really like is is
there a polynomial size heading set for
these formulas there's so so weak they
can't even compute the middle meal but
we still don't have a fully understand
full understanding of them we don't know
answer this question the best result is
a s to log log s for size f's formula
anyways I'll think I'll stop with that
the answer is yeah I mean there's not
really anything that's hard that's
computed by these things I mean they can
compute small monomials I mean basically
you can yeah they don't really so I can
tell you that they have actually come up
in catan Molly's papers on this little
nether normalization that he's been
doing you really wanted actually
identity testing exactly of this model
because he was doing invariant theory
for the special linear group of constant
size matrices I think so that came up
there but I think the rain the rain
reason that we study this is basically
because there are various techniques
that go on and this is sort of at the
intersection of every technique that
works in algebraic complexity and yet we
still can't understand this directly
from this and slow down this way okay so
obvious question is like they're these
things called non-community peas and
there's a white box at any test for
these things which is here I talked
about black box where you're really
using evaluation points but you can
generally ask you know what if you
really look at the structure and Rajesh
poker gave a pollen time algorithm to
decide that and actually that algorithm
actually does give pulling the time for
this model also so if I give you one of
these things you can actually decide in
punggol time whether it computes the
zero polynomial but you're not
necessarily using evaluation points but
I think the answer is basically no to
your question like you can't I mean this
robust lower bound idea seems to work
well in the black box case white box
case